sébastien boussois bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur rt france alors
l'organe de propagande de des chances et
l'aide de madère annaba donc consacré
une page à la tacc dans son numéro
publié il ya deux jours un mois donc
après les faits comment comprendre ce
délai est ce qu'on peut confirmer avec
certitude que le groupe terroriste est à
l'origine de cette attaque
oui je crois qu'aujourd'hui la formation
a été largement largement confirmée je
dirais que c'était un secret de
polichinelle en réalité même si on
connaît un certain nombre de tensions
qui existent sur le terrain et notamment
évidemment en particulier au sahel
il est extrêmement important de remettre
en perspective les tensions locales et
régionales et je crois que ça c'est une
des raisons qui fait et qui font que des
ch peut parfois ce que l'on appelle la
maison mère en l'occurrence mettre un
certain temps avant de corroborer ou en
tout cas de confirmer que les actes qui
ont été commis ont bien été commis au
nom de sa propre organisation
je crois que ça c'est la démonstration
de l'importance et de la force encore de
dh
malgré les rivalités locales qui dure
depuis des années entre al-qaïda est sur
le terrain des chats la fois
l'organisation al mourabitine par
exemple de moctar ben moctar qui avait
fait des attentats en 2016 qui avait eu
beaucoup d'échos internationale et puis
l'organisation de walid al sahraouis
actuellement donc l'état islam et l état
islamique au grand sahara qui avait déjà
évoqué ces attentats l'été l'été dernier
alors non reconnaissance également avait
mis du temps en 2015 2016 dont il ya
toujours un petit land effectivement de
délai avant une reconnaissance et une
validation officielle
alors c'est vrai vous l'évoquez quand on
pense au niger plus largement à la zone
du sahel on parle souvent du groupe
djihadiste akemi par exemple la branche
d'al qaïda qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de
la présence de neige dans cette zone
je pense que il faut à la fois bien
comprendre que ces groupes sont des
groupes au départ hyperlocaux et qui
sont également des groupes tout à fait
caméléon d organisation sur le terrain
comme boko haram par exemple ont
rapidement fait allégeance à dice en
al mourabitoun donc la sentinelle dont
j'ai parlé précédemment a également fait
allégeance quelques mois après la
proclamation de l'état islamique en
syrie et en irak je crois qu'il ya un
opportunisme extrêmement fort de la part
de groupes locaux qui cherchent une
revendication avec une assise locale
très importante et qui ont besoin
d'exister soit par la rapine locale soit
par des prises d'otages et en général en
termes de communication et d'image
malheureusement ce type d'attentât a un
impact extrêmement fort mais ces groupes
là aujourd'hui ont bien compris que des
jets xizt plus que jamais ce n'est pas
parce que le territoire local a été je
dirais détruit que la franchise dahesh
que la marque aujourd'hui n'existent
plus ou en tout cas n'a plus de crédit
elle en a encore énormément dans près de
40 pays dans le monde qui ont une
franchise et je crois que almora bitoun
comme l'état islamique au grand sahara
ont compris que eux devaient continuer
le combat et résisté pendant que
d'autres comme certains groupes d'aqmi
par exemple ont fait le choix et c'est
ça qui a créé des tensions également
avec les des shs logo on fait le choix
d'entamer quelques négociations avec le
gouvernement du mali ou du niger par
exemple depuis elle depuis quelques mois
mais tout cela devait se faire à
condition que l'armée française sans
lier les choses sont loin d'être gagné
pour le moment juste avant ce que ce que
vous nous dites aujourd'hui c'est que
l'organisation des ch est toujours aussi
puissante malgré les opérations
militaires ici ou là en soit avec les
français et les américains
oui parce que la démonstration et cela
se prouve depuis la guerre au vietnam en
passant par la guerre en afghanistan
passant par la guerre en irak nos armées
conventionnelles même si elle tente de
s'adapter à ce type de groupes et de
guérilla locales ne parvient pas à venir
à bout de ce type de fonctionnement de
cette hydre djihadistes qui se décompose
et se recompose dès que l'on assassiné
un dirigeant d'autres émergent et je
crois qu'il ya aussi un facteur
extrêmement important de ce que
j'appellerais la domination
charismatique de ses leaders puisque que
ça soit le sahraoui ou moctar ben moctar
ils sont toujours vivants
ils sont des icônes de la résistance il
date de l'afghanistan ça fait donc
trente ans à 40 ans que l'on entre a
qu'un certain nombre et ses leaders à
reviennent à mener une guerre
extrêmement offensive et l'opération
barkan même avec 5100 soldats français
ne parvient malheureusement pas à
grand-chose même avec le soutien du g5 e
sahel et des pays africains
on voit bien qu'il faudra adopter
d'autres méthodes contre ces groupes
djihadistes qui résistent plus que
jamais au terrain local avec parfois
aussi le soutien indirect et
l'assentiment de certaines populations
locales pour conclure en quelques mots
vous parlez de l'opération barkan vous
expliquer la difficulté est ce qu on
veut parler d'un bourbier aujourd'hui
pour les militaires français
on y est malheureusement clairement je
ne sais pas personnellement s'il
faudrait se retirer ou y rester le mali
au niger et ces pays là ont besoin de ce
soutien la cpi sont administrativement
et parfois bureaucratiquement encore
assez ferme
en terme de jeu dirait de monopole de la
violence légitime si je puis dire
l'un comme l'autre ne sont pas de bonne
solution
on comprend bien que si al qaida accepte
de négocier al qaïda au maghreb
islamique accepte de négocier avec le
gouvernement en échange d'un d'un
retrait de l'armée française
la question sera de savoir si certains
de ces groupes terroristes extrémistes
sont prêts à rentrer dans le jeu de la
démocratie par une voie politique comme
le hezbollah le fait au liban par
exemple par la voix du parti amal ça je
crois qu'on en est loin parce que
l'objectif de ces groupes c'est quand
même de détruire les états pour y
imposer un califat
merci beaucoup sébastien boussois
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes docteur en
sciences politiques et spécialiste du
terrorisme